welcome to the program Japan and South
Korea say North Korea has launched a
missile off the east coast of the Korean
Peninsula Japan's government temporarily
sounded air sirens in Hokkaido expecting
the missile to land near the island the
country's land Ministry warned planes
flying in Japan's airspace about the
missile South Korea's Coast Guard says
it could be a ballistic missile
Robert bright joins us now from Seoul uh
Rob what more do we know about this
missile launch
yeah it does seem to be one of the uh
more provocative longer range missiles
that we know North Korea has and has
been uh testing it was detected just
before 7 30 a.m local time Thursday
morning being launched from close to
Pyongyang from where the north has
launched its longer range missiles
before now it was determined to be
traveling East as they invariably do and
it was while it was over the sea that
separates the Korean Peninsula from
Japan that the authorities in the
Northern Ireland of Hokkaido issued this
alert for people to take shelter saying
that they were tracking this missile and
it was it would imminently land the fear
being that it may or parts of the debris
may have landed around the island before
now on some of the more provocative
launches that the north has carried out
they have fired missiles over the top of
Hokkaido out into the Pacific Ocean this
actually fell a lot shorter than
Hokkaido but it was determined to have
had quite a lofty trajectory it went up
to an altitude they reckon of around 3
000 kilometers and the icbms the
intercontinental ballistic missiles that
we know the north has and has been
testing they have reached an altitude an
apogee of around 6 000 kilometers so
they're still trying to determine
whether this was a medium range or an
ICBM in recent weeks Rob dare I said
even in recent months we've sort of seen
various announcements from the north
about missile launches so what sort of
expectation is there where you are that
there may be more to come
yeah there's been increasing
anticipation that the north Was
preparing um a more provocative type of
missile test there's been increasingly
belligerent rhetoric coming out of the
North about the uh joint military
exercises taking place this spring
between the U.S and South Korean forces
also April sees a number of important
anniversaries and we know that the north
will often Mark those anniversaries with
some sort of dramatic missile test and
we have in a couple of days here the
so-called day of the sun that's the
111th anniversary of the birth date of
Kim il-sung the founder of North Korea
and also finally the north has not been
picking up the hotline those hotlines
that exist between the South and the
north who try to de-escalate tensions
and clear up any misunderstandings they
make in the mornings and afternoons a
regular phone call just to make sure the
lines are working well since last Friday
so that's six days nearly a week the
north simply hasn't been picking up
Rob it's good to hit the update of
course we'll follow events with you from
South Korea as the hours progress thank
you